December 2023, ST Blitz board meeting.
Eric Simons walks into the room knowing
that his company is dying. 7 years of
building this revolutionary web
container technology, millions raised,
but the revenue is practically zero and
the growth is practically flat. The
board gives him an ultimatum. You show
us real progress by the end of 2024 or
we shut this down. Just two months
later, bold new is showcasing explosive
growth. 20 million error in just two
months. And today, 18 months later, we
expect to see another update crossing
over 100 million AR for B. This
overnight success didn't really happen
overnight. It took 7 years in the
making. And today, I'm going to tell you
exactly how that happened so you can
replicate it for your business. I'm
Victoria from Evil Martians, the go-to
agency for developer tools. We've been
Staglit's technical partner since 2021,
back when nobody believed in browser
based technology, web containers, and
investors thought that this was the dead
end. We work with 40 plus early stage
developer tools startups each year, and
everybody is asking the same question.
How do I bring AI into my product?
First, let's talk about what doesn't
work. The most common mistake I see is
let's sprinkle some AI into our UI. And
the problem with that is people are very
tired of chatbot interfaces at this
point. It's very hard to convince
yourself to try something new to test
new features because oftent times the
results are underwhelming. So, if you
are just slapping on a chatbot, you're
taking a risk. your customers might just
lose interest and never try it again and
the result will be very sad as well. A
quietly deprecated
feature. The second common trap I see is
boiling the ocean. When you are trying
to AI power everything, you're competing
with the big guys like OpenAI and
Anthropic. And the reality is you just
don't have that big of a team and that
big of an investment behind you. Uh
instead try to think about what you can
leverage. What's your unique domain?
What's your unique expertise? What's
your unique technology? If we bet on
that, the chances that we succeed are
much higher. Then there are companies
that are waiting for the AI to be
perfect. And the reality is we have to
build the tooling as we go. It's up to
us. If we get scrappy, if we get
creative with our solutions, we will
stay ahead of the game. But the biggest
killer, not talking to users. I've seen
many companies reinvent the wheel,
invest a lot of money, a lot of
resources into building beautiful,
intricate interfaces that users don't
need. And the reality is no market, no
product. Talk to your users first. While
everyone else bolted AI into their
existing workflows, Stuckless did
something different. I want to take you
through three simple steps that you can
apply to your business and try to
replicate stack blitz success with bold
new. Step one, identify your unfair
advantage. Not product features, but
your unique competitive edge. Let's take
stack blitz. They're the only company
that can run a full development
environment in the browser. They don't
need containers. They don't need
servers. They don't need local setup.
What's your unique advantage? It could
be something like domain expertise or
data distribution or infrastructure, you
name it. Step two, figure out how AI can
amplify your competitive advantage. So
instead of thinking how do I bring AI
into my product, think what becomes
possible when AI meets my unique
capability. For stag was pretty
straightforward. Every other pipe coding
tool had the same issue. The process is
just too complicated for an average
user. So instead, you describe your app
with words. You see it right there in
the browser and you can share the URL
with the public.
Easy. It only became possible because
they had this unique competitive
advantage. So now it's your turn. What
becomes possible when AI meets your
unfair
advantage? Step number three, last but
not the least, create a
category. Instead of thinking in
existing workflows, think about how your
capability can change the flow
altogether. If we take a look at stag
blitz, this is called inventing a
category. They reinvented how people
vibe code. Why this moment matters? The
reality is staglit secret wasn't unique
AI. Everybody has access to
anthropic. It was their unique
competitive advantage. And once they
figured it out, they reinvented the user
flow and they bet everything on it. They
went all in. So I want to encourage you
to take a look at your product. Be
honest. Sometimes it's painful. Take a
look at your product and think what's
your unique mode. What's your
competitive
advantage? How can AI amplify that
advantage? Can you reinvent a workflow?
Can you create a category out of this
process? If you find answers to all of
those questions, you're on the right
track. Good luck.